foreign
the first most pivotal
experience for me was
closing the first restaurant I ever
closed which was Tabla an Indian
restaurant interestingly
Tabla was about 13 years old and if I
regret one thing that I wrote in setting
the table it was actually in the very
first paragraph of the book
and I proudly stated at this at this
point we had been in business for about
20 years and I proudly stated how many
restaurants we had opened
and then I super proudly stated and in
all that time we've never closed one
as if closing a restaurant is failure
and it was the stupidest thing I could
have possibly written because
closing a restaurant is not failing and
it's nothing it's also nothing to be
ashamed of and
nothing to be proud of to keep a
restaurant open forever it either it is
or it isn't
so
Tableau I guarantee you I was so
falsely proud with what I had written
that I kept Tablo and I was so afraid of
my dad's you know I didn't want to go
down the path of being my dad you
telling me that something I couldn't
make something work here
Tabla was a great Indian
expression with you know in a very
groundbreaking way in New York City
using fresh green Market ingredients we
had a fantastic chef who sadly died
during covid Floyd cardos
groundbreaking restaurant lived for 13
years
probably should have closed it at year
11. we had just hit the Great Recession
and
we started to lose money
it was our biggest restaurant
in terms of numbers of seats we had 283
seats on three different dining rooms
two different levels
I was so afraid of closing it so afraid
of talking to the team and saying we
couldn't make couldn't make the
restaurant work that I kept it open for
two years longer than I should have
and that was the restaurant where
for two years we had people working
out of loyalty no one was making a raise
no one was getting a promotion
and
I finally gathered the courage to do
what I should have done two years sooner
and
I'll never forget the day I I said look
what if we could distinguish ourselves
as much based on
how well we closed a restaurant as we
had with how well we had opened the
restaurant
and and so we started writing a list of
all right what are all the ways that we
could look back on this and say we did
it the right way
and first thing was
we told our whole staff
right now that sounds well why is that
such a big well sadly in in our business
sometimes the first time a staff learns
a restaurant's going out of business is
the day they go to work and see a
padlock on the door because the
restaurant is dead afraid
that no one will work there no one wants
to stay on a sinking ship so we told our
staff quarter of year ahead of time
told our landlord told the community
we invited all of the alumni of the
restaurant in to come cook with us
so we celebrated the restaurant
we hosted job fairs for all of our team
members
not just not just with us teaching them
how to interview and working potentially
in our other restaurants but again
inviting
famous chefs who had once cooked with us
or general managers who had once worked
with us to come in and hire our staff
we hosted three fundraisers we we
brought in Indian chefs from around the
country to do a fundraiser for
earthquake victims in India we did a
fundraiser for Madison Square Park so by
the time this was done we paid our
landlord everything
we actually even paid our investors like
I think they got it
point one percent return on their
original invest they got all their money
back plus a couple pennies
so if you're going to close a place at
least that was the way to do it and the
biggest learning I had was there's no
shame in closing
since closing Tabla
I would say we've probably opened 15
restaurants and we've probably closed
another six
and we had to close about three of them
during covid
and I think that learning to fail fast
and realize that if you hadn't tried the
thing in the first place
there would neither have been a success
or failure so the real failure would
have been not in trying
but not everything has to go on forever
the late restaurateur Joe bomb had this
great expression
that I love and I don't love but he used
to say
that the definition of a classic
restaurant is one that can outlive its
original lease
and that's you know that was a goal of
mine for a long long time and we've
frankly we've done that with almost all
of our restaurants
I now have a different goal of my own
which is I want our restaurants
and I think your podcast is this as well
and we all have songs in our lives that
are like this or pieces of art or movies
or books but I want our restaurants to
become essential in people's lives I
want people to say my life got better
because that restaurant existed doesn't
matter how long
and and God forbid the restaurant goes
out of business I want people to say I
just lost a little something when that
restaurant closed there's so many
restaurants
dry cleaners whatever they come and go
and it's like who cares there's so many
songs and I never heard it again I'd be
fine but there's this handful of songs
that when I listen to them
I'm grateful for the person who wrote it
I'm grateful for their life
my life got better because that song
existed
and I can't even imagine my life if that
song had never been written that's my
more than longevity it's essentiality
that I think matters